in this video we're going to learn to
make a movie in Pinal so you might be
asking why would I want to do that well
you could be that person with an
impressive video embedded in your
PowerPoint with your protein that you're
working on spinning behind you and
zooming the active site and wouldn't
that be pretty cool okay let's begin
we're going to use the work that we did
in the videos where we created scenes
and where we created labels so if you'd
like to work along with me which I
recommend run through those two
tutorials and so we're right about here
okay scenes are going to enable you to
make a movie really really well when I
left off I had actually I had something
else stored as scene five and then I
repositioned this so I want to actually
make this scene five but I've already
stored scene five well if we're typing
commands we actually can update our
scenes really really easily so I'm just
going to type seeing five comma update
and now this is what's stored here as
scene five let's just double check we'll
click to scene four click back to scene
five beautiful that's exactly what I
wanted so we can update our scenes as we
go now you might have noticed when I
click back to scene for my ligands
changed color because I was using
magenta at the time and then I changed
my mind
no problem let's go ahead and update
that we have a selection for our ligands
over here we'll go to ligands color by
element and choose white for our ligands
so now they're recolored let's click
into this area right here the command
line and we want to store this as scene
four so we're going to update the
previous scene for that we had
okay now we have seen five which zooms
in are on our interactions with the
phosphate group here seen four and our
ligands are colored the same color so
our movies going to look pretty good
let's check on scene three
okay and we can see here our ligand was
colored blue the color of the protein at
the time so we can just go ahead two
ligands color by element pick our color
oops not yellow there's that white and
now click in the command line click the
up arrow and we can quickly just change
this to scene 3 same command comes
through so we're using the arrow keys
remember to toggle through those
commands there now let's go back and see
what we had for scene
- ok our ligands were green so let's go
ahead and color our ligands again by
element and change them to the white but
we had other ligands shown so all I want
is to show these ligands so I'm gonna
click on them these little lights light
up in the sequence I'm gonna scroll over
till I'm within them and I want to see
all the ligands so I can see here so
these 3 were the ones that were
important to me and this just makes the
protein a little bit busy there here in
the structure but I just don't want to
show them right now because I want the
viewer to be focusing on this active
site so it looks like these are the
things that I don't need here so
starting with this magnesium this ADP is
important so skip that one so first of
all just click away and now we're gonna
make a new selection we don't want to
add to the selection of our good ligands
so we're just going to go like this and
I can drag and select all of these and I
can make a selection out of this right
now I just want to hide everything so
I'm gonna hide everything and now we
only see the little stick ligand in that
active site and that'll look pretty good
for our movie so let's store this use
the up arrow key we don't want to store
this as scene 3 we're gonna store it as
scene 2 and update so let's just check
by clicking through we hadn't seen one
as well that was the rainbow I don't
think we'll use that in this one we'll
just stick to this - zooms in a little
bit adds the water and zooms a little
bit more and then scene 5 zooms in on
our interactions with the phosphate
which maybe we want to hide
so we're gonna put those elements
together in a movie and we're gonna
start with scene two so I can just click
on that and get that centered my vision
for this movie is we're gonna have our
protein here it's going to spin around
and then we're going to zoom through
scene three and four get all the way to
scene five and then this is going to do
a slow turn and then we'll zoom back out
all the way so we have our protein in
frame again because if we wanted to loop
our movie we might want it to smoothly
transition right to where it started so
we will start and end on scene - okay
let's make a 20-second movie pi mol
makes movies at 30 frames per second
pretty standard so 20 times 30 we need
600 frames in our movie the magic
command that we type to make a movie is
M set M se T and we want our movie to
range from frame 1 a little X all the
way to frame 600 and that sets up our
movie now down here you see the word
camera so we're gonna get a timeline for
a movie building down here okay now we
want to store the views along our
timeline for our movie and so the
command to do that is abuse store and
this is where we're going to start so we
want this to be the M view that we store
at frame 1 and watch at the bottom when
I do this you'll see the little line
comes up now so that line is going to
have little breaks on it where we're
doing little clips in our movie so let's
say I want this to spin around for about
200 frames this is the scene I'm going
to want to end on because I'm gonna do
just a 360 turning on the y-axis so I'm
gonna go ahead and use my arrow key and
we're gonna also store this at frame 200
now if I want this to spin evenly and
smoothly over 200 frames I can always
like click on this and drag it around to
wherever I wanted it and then store that
view that's fine I'm gonna go straight
back to opes the the second scene here I
want it to turn really smoothly so what
I'm gonna do is use another command turn
y 180 degrees you could do this in the
x-direction if you want no problem and
so I'm gonna execute that and it turns
my protein perfectly now I want to store
this midway between here so I had stored
the just seen too in its original form
I'd sorted at 0 and 200 so let me store
the Y turn at 100 so using my arrow keys
and I can just fix this one to the the
where I want to store it so you can do
this really quite quickly now you can
see another little band popped up right
here and that's where we stored this
view so now we can type em play just to
see how our movie is doing and that'll
show us our movie it spins it comes back
around and then we don't have anything
else so it's going to do nothing for a
while so let's go ahead and hit em stop
so we're stopping playing our movie and
I think we can type frame 1 and go all
the way back to frame 1 if we wanted to
basically rewind so we have this
spinning till frame 200 and then we want
to pan gently to this scene 3 here and
so I am going to store scene 3 at oh
let's say 300 so I'm on this view so I
can just go back to one of my old and
view stores and make that 300 so it'll
slowly pan between here and here to this
scene and I said can also I'm just gonna
play it for a second stop it now and
then I can take this little guy and drag
it with my cursor so if I want to just
take a quick view ok that's working
right great that's
actually what I wanted to happen so you
can kind of preview as you go without
watching the entire movie every time
which is really good if you're making a
long movie okay now we want to pan to
scene for so scene for ads in our waters
and turns the structure site slightly
I'm going to find one of my M view
stores and let's store this at 350 okay
the final thing I wanted to do was go to
my phosphate interactions that I'd shown
so I'm going to click on scene 5 and
store that basically the way that time
will smoothly pan that's what I'm going
to be seeing in my movie as well so
let's store this at 400 and we'll see
right around here another little thing
come up there it is
so we've stored this here and now let's
say we want to spin this around almost
until the end of our movie but then we
want our movie to zoom back out to scene
2 so let's plan to spin from 400 to
frame 550 so now we can we've stored
this already at 400 and so we want to
end here at 550 so we can just store
this again let's do our good old turn y
180 command to get exactly where we want
and again you could do this manually you
could move to wherever you wanted over
it over the time period you know you can
have it spin very slowly for the first
half and speed up but I like to just
have a very very uniform spin so halfway
between four frames 400 and 550 is gonna
be 475
so let's store this at 475 and then I
set at the end of our movie we wanted to
come back to scene 2 because that's
where we started in case we want to loop
this so let's just go ahead and do that
and we'll store this as the last frame
all right so let's go to frame 1 and so
that just took our cursor all the way
back so we could play our movie from the
beginning and here we go so we have our
spin the spin is finishing now we're
gonna zoom in on our scene 3 and you
could see the scenes light up as they're
changing 2 zooms over that's kind of
fast maybe you want to slow that down
after you watch it that'd be fine so you
just have to make a longer movie zooms
all the way back out and now we're just
looping and so it's spinning again now
we're ready to export our movie so maybe
you want to embed it into PowerPoint so
we can go to file export movie as and
you may have any of these options
highlighted some of the free versions I
don't know if they could do the MPEG in
QuickTime if you export this as PNG
images you'll need something that puts
those images back together in a movie
later so you'll just get a file folder
with a lot of images in it but I like to
save it as an MPEG so here we go it'll
ask me if I want to do any of these
commands I tried to Rae this before and
make very beautiful structures and my
computer hung up forever so I just
always do the draw and then you can save
the movie as wherever you want it so
we'll just save that and you can watch
it as it goes through and it'll be
saving it you can close this window at
this time so I hope you enjoyed learning
a little bit about how to make a movie
in Pinal with me I hope you find it
useful and maybe make a beautiful
presentation with this someday and if
you want to learn more about pommel
chemistry and biochemistry like this
video subscribe to my channel